- Now performing "Weekends"
from their album, "Another Life",
give it up for Big Time Rush.
(audience cheering and clapping)
(gentle music)
♪ Mm, mm, mm, mm ♪
♪ I know it's a weeknight ♪
♪ It's been a minute since
you hit me with a reply ♪
♪ Mm, mm ♪
♪ Something don't seem right ♪
♪ We used to talk every day,
now it's once in a while ♪
♪ Yeah, once in a while ♪
♪ It's funny how every word
I ate made my stomach ache ♪
♪ Was it all for nothing ♪
♪ Must be my mistake ♪
♪ This run around got me in
a state, overcompensate ♪
♪ I was what you wanted ♪
♪ Now, you don't even look my way ♪
♪ Can you just let me know ♪
♪ Why you're so hot and cold ♪
♪ I wanna know the reason ♪
♪ You only call me on the weekends ♪
♪ Either love me or let me go ♪
♪ You say you will, but you don't ♪
♪ I wanna know the reason ♪
♪ You only call me on the weekends, yeah ♪
♪ I can see you posting on your page ♪
♪ Then you go and ghost, why the games ♪
♪ Maybe we're just on different waves ♪
♪ Maybe the you I knew has changed ♪
♪ I don't wanna believe it ♪
♪ It's funny how every word
I ate made my stomach ache ♪
♪ Was it all for nothing ♪
♪ Must be my mistake ♪
♪ This run around got me in
a state, overcompensate ♪
♪ I was what you wanted ♪
♪ Now, you don't even look my way ♪
♪ Can you just let me know ♪
♪ Why you're so hot and cold ♪
♪ I wanna know the reason ♪
♪ You only call me on the weekends ♪
♪ Either love me or let me go ♪
♪ You say you will, but you don't ♪
♪ I wanna know the reason ♪
♪ You only call me on the weekends ♪
♪ Where you at tonight, oh, where you at ♪
♪ Be honest 'bout the reason ♪
♪ Then I can let it go ♪
♪ Where you at tonight, where you at ♪
♪ I think I know the reason, oh ♪
♪ Can you just let me know ♪
♪ Why you're so hot and cold ♪
♪ I wanna know the reason ♪
♪ You only call me on the weekends ♪
♪ Either love me or let me go ♪
♪ You say you will, but you don't ♪
♪ I wanna know the reason ♪
♪ You only call me on the weekends ♪
♪ Oh, yeah, oh, yeah, oh,
yeah, oh, yeah, oh, yeah ♪
♪ Call me on the weekends ♪
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Once more, put your hands together
for Big Time Rush, everybody.
Pickup their new deluxe version
of their album, "Another Life",
wherever you get your music.
We'll be right back in a moment.